hard as it may be to believe scream is
about to celebrate its 20th anniversary
which begs the question what is the
cat's been up to for the last two
decades see who made it big and who's
still trying and our look at where the
castor scream is today Neve Campbell s
franchise heroine Sidney Prescott Neve
Campbell remained with The Scream
franchise for all four films all while
maintaining a role in the award-winning
TV series party of five outside of those
hits however her career has been a
little patchy she's appeared in a
handful of movies including critically
acclaimed turns in win will I be loved
and the ballet drama the company
television though seems to be where she
truly belongs she's more recently landed
high-profile guest spots on hit shows
like Grey's Anatomy and Mad Men finally
landing a more regular role on the hit
Netflix series house of cards Courtney
Cox much like Campbell did for Sydney
Courtney Cox were priests her role is
pushing news reporter Gale weathers in
the subsequent Scream sequels while also
sticking by her insanely popular series
friends until it ended its 10-year run
in 2004 Cox's post screen career
stumbled out of the gate however her
first major gig the FX tabloid drama
dirt was panned by critics and cancelled
after two seasons but a popular guest
spot on scrubs led to a Golden Globe
nominated role on the comedy Cougar Town
which ran for six seasons David Arquette
also a scream lifer
David Arquette continued to play the
affably dopey deputy Dewey throughout
the entire series between those movies
his career has been a bit of a
head-scratcher while he gained even more
popularity opposite Drew Barrymore in
the 1999 romantic comedy never been
kissed later roles tended to be discount
DVD bin fare like ready to rumble see
spot run and eight legged freaks TV has
been a bit kinder to Arquette however
he's appeared on everything from Pushing
Daisies to the crackle series cleaners
and Dancing with the Stars Skeet Ulrich
possibly because Billy Loomis was one of
the scariest teenagers of all time
sceeto arches career on the big screen
was insanely short-lived despite being a
recognizable name all rich hasn't really
landed another major film role instead
making a handful of appearances on
television including the cult favourite
Jericho and various crime dramas like
CSI New York and
order LA he returned a horror in 2016
with her role in the movie escape room
but his best role will always be his
appearance in South Park Matthew Lillard
after scream Matthew Lillard gained a
bit of street cred thanks to his
starring role in the cult indie drama
SLC punk his career quickly took a turn
in teenage drama DS like she's all that
and some catch
followed by a stint as the eerily
accurate shaggy in the live-action
scooby-doo movies which earned him the
role of voicing the animated shaggy as
well this is also he's also made a few
notable appearances on movies and TV
including The Good Wife and the
oscar-winning George Clooney flick The
Descendants Lillard announced on Twitter
that he'll be appearing on Showtime's
much-anticipated Twin Peaks continuation
saying I play someone epic Jamie Kennedy
for a few years Jamie Kennedy seemed
like he was poised for a successful
movie career roles and movies like three
kings and boiler room kept his profile
high and even Malibu's Most Wanted made
a bit of money despite mediocre reviews
and then came 2005
son of the mask
[Music]
the unnecessary sequel to the classic
Jim Carrey comedy damask the film was a
colossal disaster with critics and
audiences earning just 17 million
domestically against an 84 million
dollar budget it also earned Kennedy two
Razzie nominations including one for
worst screen couple which he shared with
anyone stuck sharing the screen with him
from there he made headlines for
appearing on Ghost Whisperer and briefly
dating its star Jennifer Love Hewitt he
also became the subject of Internet
infamy when a disastrous New Year's Eve
special he hosted on local television in
Southern California went viral in
January 2013 where's our where's our
stage manager there's a fight it's
ending with a fight Rose McGowan after
getting crushed by a garage door and
then co-starring in the teen comedy
jawbreaker Rose McGowan became best
known for replacing shannen doherty in
the WB supernatural drama d Charmed
where she remained through the series
finale in 2006 she went on to appear in
the grindhouse movies by director Robert
Rodriguez to whom she was also very
briefly engaged she tastes like troubles
[Music]
with an attitude to boot other
high-profile roles include guest spots
on nip/tuck and Law & Order Special
Victims Unit and a terrifying period as
Marilyn Manson's fiancee W Earl Brown
after playing Gale weathers food-loving
cameraman Kenny W Earl brown has shown
up in countless roles on television and
movies arguably his most famous roles
remained and/or D on the beloved HBO
drama Deadwood and Cameron Diaz's
brother Warren in the 1998 comedy
there's something about meri recent
appearances also include spots on
American crime and true detective Liev
Schreiber although it's character cotton
weary only appeared in news footage in
the first screen movie Liev Schreiber
went on to play a more prominent role in
scream 2 & 3 over the last 20 years
whether in the movies on television or
the Broadway stage
Schreiber has become one of Hollywood's
more acclaimed and respected actors he
received an Emmy nomination for playing
Orson Welles in the 2000 TV movie RKO to
81 and a few years later he won a Tony
Award in the Broadway revival of
Glengarry Glen Ross he since appeared in
a number of movies including The
Manchurian Candidate remake from 2004
salt and x-men origins Wolverine he also
earned a starring role in the Showtime
drama ray Donovan for which he's
received two Emmy and three Golden Globe
nominations thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which classic film stars you'd like
to catch up with
you